a terrible thing to have coronavirus
were you sitting there at home in all
seriousness were you sitting at home
going oh my god I'm gonna die did you
think because you know everyone is so no
you know what I had the symptoms that
that you read about which is fever tight
chest achy no sense of smell
cough the thing I'm asthmatic so I was
the lungs are the thing that that that
are what you should monitor and be
concerned about my doctors advised me
early on to get something called a pulse
pulse oximeter which is something you
can get at the drugstore and it's just
this little device that you stick your
finger in that takes your pulse but it
also measures how much oxygen your lungs
are getting and he gave me a reading and
he said if it goes below this number
call me so I kind of knew then yeah and
I was I was sticking my finger in this
thing all day long and just making sure
that it was okay and that is what kept
me calm do you have any clue how you got
it I mean were you I mean I I have this
image of you as like carrying on with
everybody and socializing and talking
and going you know what I'm not gonna
get the [ __ ] corona virus or
something like that I don't know I mean
they could have I mean I hate to say it
but it could have been anybody it was
that we it was the week I think my first
symptoms started around the 16th or so a
large so it was that week before that I
was still doing watch what happens live
I was that serious I was I was on stage
at 54 below one I mean I was all over
the place that week what did you do with
your son when you when you know you have
coronavirus you can't explain away from
him for I stayed away from him for I
think it was 13 days total I saw him
yesterday for the first time right I
think that it's important that if you
get it and you start having these
symptoms you you have to say okay well
the odds are with me that's what I felt
I knew immediately either
had to self quarantine from my son which
was the most important thing and that I
had to start taking tylenol and drinking
a lot of fluids and monitor my myself on
this little pulse oximeter so that's the
thing that I think that you can't panic
if 84 if the odds are that 80% of you
are gonna get it in a case like I had
then you have to just let it work
through your system
you